you are mostly in pairs
and you'll have your deck of playing
cards okay now between the two of you
you're each gonna have
different roles during what we're doing
today okay so for starters i'd love one
of you in the pair to have the entire
deck of playing cards there in your hand
and if you haven't already
i'd love you to mix it up and by the way
i'm just going to show you my cards here
you can see it's a deck just like yours
in fact some of you might even have this
exact color there's repeats
it's all mixed up i'll mix it up a
little more as well you can do like that
fancy i can't actually do it i don't
have enough hand-eye coordination you
know that one where you split it in two
and you're like try and okay this is
just a recipe for disaster because i'm
doing in front of people now it's
something like this now see how badly
that went and then you sort of ripple it
together
or you can um you can just mix it on the
table this is what they call a casino
wash it's very um it's very effective at
making sure everything's jumbled up
it's important that you do that by the
way because
i want us all to have a different order
of the playing cards that you can see in
front of you you'll see why that's
important in a second okay so can you
just do a quick check make sure it isn't
like you know accidentally in some kind
of order it's all jumbled up so mixed up
are you satisfied give me a nod if
that's looking okay for you yeah
excellent thank you all right
so
i said that one of you is going to have
the deck of playing cards in their hands
and that person with the deck in their
hands right now i'd love you to make
sure that everything you're going to see
me do that you also follow my steps
exactly okay i'll do it slow enough and
i'll talk through what i'm doing to make
sure that you're watching carefully for
the person who does not have the deck in
their hands you actually have a harder
job
your job is number one you have to watch
me that i'm not up to any monkey
business i'm not doing anything sneaky
i'm i'm not like pulling a trick on you
i'm genuinely doing all the things i'm
describing um and to that end i'm going
to take off my watch because i've done
this many times before and some people
say like something up your sleeve you
know nothing suspicious here okay
person who doesn't have the deck in the
cards in their hands in addition to
watching me
i also want you to make sure that your
partner who has got the cards is
following these steps closely and isn't
missing anything it's actually
deceptively easy okay
that's the task i'll give you a few more
things to do later on but for now are we
clear what we're doing
excellent okay so
deck in hand the first thing i'd like
you to do is look at the first card on
the top and mine's the queen of diamonds
you might have a queen you might have a
diamond as well what we're really paying
attention to is the color of the card
there are only two kinds of colors in a
deck of playing cards and those are red
and
black right if you've got a red card
like me i'd love you to put that on the
right hand side of the table red on the
right if you've got a black card just
place it on the left
and wherever you put your card on the
right or the left i'd also like you to
match your face up card
with a face
down card so don't look at it so you can
see face up face down if you've got a
black card over here then it'll be face
up face down so far so good okay and
we're going to repeat this process i've
got another red card so red cards go on
there
right face up and then face down i'm
just putting them right over the top
and then i'm just going to keep on going
uh i never know what's going to come
next face up face down
another red face up face down i'm
waiting for a black one face up face
down finally there we go face up face
down okay let me pause here right
now
this process that we've begun
is going to create these four piles of
cards in front of us do you see that
okay now we're going to do this for the
entire deck
but as we do this now you see where it's
going to go
keep on putting the cards down face up
and face down but listen to my voice as
you do so okay there's a few things i
want you to observe about my cards and
about yours
the first thing is they are coming out
in a completely unpredictable order
completely unpredictable like you never
know whether it's black or red you never
know what number is coming out or if
it's like a jack queen king we call them
the court cards right it's completely
unpredictable right now this is not a
rhetorical question
can anyone tell me
why is it unpredictable the co order of
the cards coming out it's actually
because of something i asked you to do
at the start
any takers yeah go ahead
you mix them all up fantastic and this
is the point in me asking you to jumble
them up have them very shuffled because
i presume
your order of cards is different to mine
and your order of cards is different to
the person sitting next to you and we're
all in fact
all of us in this room getting something
different
now it's not just all of us in this room
there are a lot of ways to
shuffle a deck of playing cards 52 cards
right and by the way for those of you
whose job it was to watch me i'm glad
some of you are doing this some of you
have gotten distracted um i'm not
touching the cards please note but i'm
just going to move the screen for a
second so i can write something down
okay the number of ways they are to
shuffle a deck of playing cards is a
very large number if you think about
like say the first card on the top
there's 52 different possibilities for
what that card is and then when you go
to the next one it's this 51
possibilities and then there's 50 for
the third card down and you just keep on
doing this all the way down to the final
cards the last one is just one option
right now this is a number which as you
can see it takes a long time to describe
mathematicians very lazy we give this
number a name we call it 52
factorial you might have heard that word
before if you haven't already don't
worry you're going to encounter it in
years to come
this number
is enormous if you go ahead to your
calculator and you punch this into your
calculator it's going to tell you i
actually need to leave a little bit of
space here
it's going to tell you
80 million
which sounds like a large number right
it is and then it says oh and by the way
put another 60 zeros after that i don't
even know you know how there's like
billions and trillions and quadrillions
i don't even know what this is called
okay it's an enormous number it's so
large that
if all eight billion people who are
alive on the planet right now did
nothing but shuffle decks of playing
cards at a rate of like how long does it
take to do it properly like once a
minute
for the age of the like the planet earth
which is about four and a half billion
years
this number is so much larger than
everyone on the planet doing that for
that long that we wouldn't even have
scratched the surface of how many
possibilities there are
to shuffle a deck of playing cards which
is to say
that order that well this order that
i've got and that order that you've got
it's probably never been shuffled in
that order in the history of humanity
and it probably never will again
so you have a little piece of history
sitting in front of you okay
now that was the first thing i want to
point out that it's unpredictable it's
also unknown though isn't it did you
notice we got these face down cards and
presumably like me you weren't even
looking at them you weren't counting you
got no idea what they were right now
it's unpredictable it's unknown believe
it or not we're going to try and make
this even more mixed up and jumbled um
it's annabelle right annabelle could you
pick for all of us a number between one
and five
three three okay for all of you there's
two of you at the table right i would
like
one of you on the left to take three
cards from this face down pile over here
so i'm gonna just take one from the top
one from the bottom and one somewhere
from the middle i'm not even looking at
them okay
i've got three cards there let me move
these down so you can see
and then i'm also going to take three
cards from this pile over here so just
to shake things up let's just take them
all from the top one two
three and i'd love you to do the same
there's two of you there
you can each take three from both sides
and once you've done that
hold those three cards i've got three
here
and three
here
okay
so these ones that came from my left
watch carefully and this i'd like you to
follow and do as i do the three from the
left i'd like you to put them on the
right
and the three from the right i'd like
you to put them on the left
so thanks to animals choice of three
we've just taken whatever we did before
and we've jumbled it up okay
now so far so good
at this moment hands off the tables
you've been following me
so far
and you've got the same kind of same
kind of arrangement of cards in front of
you as i have been but for now i want
every single one of you to be watching
very closely closely what i'm about to
do okay
i know it doesn't feel like it yet but
this is a maths lesson i intend to teach
you something mathematical i've already
started you don't realize it
one of the key things about mathematics
for me one reason why i love teaching it
is that i view mathematics a little bit
like this pair of glasses that sits on
my face now i see most of you have
excellent vision or you're in denial and
refuse to wear glasses that's fine um
unlike you i've worn these since i was
actually a bit younger than you when i
was 12 years old i started wearing
glasses and when i first put them on i
was like whoa the world just like
snapped into focus and i could see like
words and faces instead of just blurry
things right
now i think about mathematics
like this pair of glasses because it
helps me see the world more clearly it
helps me see patterns and understand
things that are invisible to other
people including the pattern that allows
me to make a prediction
of this seemingly unpredictable
situation here's the prediction are you
ready
my prediction
is that see the number of black cards
over here
i predict the number of black cards that
are hiding in this mystery face down
pile
will match the number of
red cards
in
this mystery face down pile let me say
that one more time just so we're really
clear my prediction is the number of
black cards here will be the same as the
number of red cards here
make sense
now i need your help to see whether my
prediction is true so i'm going to take
these face down cards here and i'm going
to deal them out now and i'd love you to
count aloud with me
if and only if they are black so i'm
going to reveal them and then you're
going to count one two three yeah here
we go
okay that was the first test you passed
good job
thank you that was the second test you
also passed two two
three three it's harder than it looks
five black cards what was that
prediction again
it was that
if there were five like cards over here
i'm hoping
that there'll be five red cards in here
now by the way just i haven't looked at
them but that's that's a lot of cards
right
five red cards again you're gonna help
me by counting aloud as i deal them out
okay but only if they are
red here we go
thank you
two
three
four
five
five red cards ladies and gentlemen now
now you are shocked at the moment but
guess what it gets better even though
i've asked half of you to be watching
closely what i've been doing the whole
time to make sure i'm not up to any
monkey business i still wouldn't blame
you if you're like yeah no mr wu we
still don't believe you you could have
done something shifty without us nursing
right
but you know what i've been sat here
this whole time and i haven't gone
anywhere near your cards haven't touched
them and the prediction i made of my
cards i now make of yours what we're
looking for are the number of black
cards in this mystery pile remember it
was face down face down for you and the
number of red cards
in this mystery pile can you go the two
of you
count and tell me what you find
if you think if you think i'm just gonna
say okay everyone uh now let me show you
why that works
you're sorely mistaken because i said to
you right the beginning my intent was
for you to learn something mathematical
in this lesson and something i learned
very early when i was a teacher is that
the person doing the work and the
thinking is the person doing the
learning so i'm not going to explain
this to you
yet
you're going to have a go at trying to
understand this and i'm going to try and
sort of guide you in this a little bit
okay
we've got some time
i'm going to give you probably 10 15
minutes to have a go at this
independently first here's what i'd like
you to begin by doing remember how one
of you started with the deck of cards in
their hand okay i want you to put those
cards back together and let the other
person do this again
when you do it again remember
i asked annabelle for a number between
one and five she chose three
i'd like you instead to pick another
number your choice now
i just chose you know the same number
for all of us just to make it a bit
simpler but i want you to now choose
and then i'd love you to get out your
books
and your pens and pencils and see if you
can work out write some workings see if
you can reason through just make a guess
a hypothesis doesn't matter if it's
right or wrong i want you to think
through it i'll leave this up on screen
if you want any questions or ideas
mrs johnson and i are going to be
roaming around just asking questions of
you good luck about 10 minutes see how
far you can get